so you'll be working free for the next
year wait we talked gummy bears after
that year
maybe one maybe green you can start for
green and then go to red
so basically you're going to work free
for a year and then what will happen is
is that after that year
i'll probably fire you and find someone
better
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with louimi tech and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs stanford
what an episode we have with us today
eddie fur bottom welcome to the studio
an a-list celebrity puppet entrepreneur
eddie is an a-list celebrity
puppet-printer with a hit youtube
channel of the same name
he's the most well-connected
entrepreneur on the planet and
incredibly famous in hollywood and is a
thought leader on the topics of
entrepreneurship mindset
and coffee that comes out of the butt of
a small tiny animal in bali
he is not yet the author of any books
yet but he will be writing one when he
can be bothered
his mission is to make entrepreneurs not
take life too seriously
and his website can be found at
www.puppetpreneurs.com
oh and he's a puppet eddie fur bottom
thank you so much for joining me on 20
minute leaders
i love having you here thank you
this is a privilege you look uh you look
very smart
thank you very much you definitely look
very very smart and
entertaining and uh eddie uh there's a
lot for us to talk about but i think the
most interesting part is to talk about
who you are
and your sort of outlook into the
entrepreneurial scene
and tell me a little bit about you know
your upbringing
and where you grew up and what you're
doing today
well i was i was brought up in england
and you know
i i really didn't like it there you know
the people were not very kind to me
kind of got bullied and so i decided
that really i wanted to move to
to america like the the land of all the
dreams you know
and all the good-looking people
especially in california you know
because they're kind of like i'm ugly
and so
you know for me california's got so many
really hot people and i'm trying to get
married and so
you know building a company trying to
get married it's kind of difficult so
you gotta you gotta be around people
that you wanna be like so
i'm ugly and i wanna be good looking i i
love that and your end along with you
know
trying to get married which i wish you
uh best of luck by the way i love the
suit i i can't imagine it'll be too hard
for you to find
the right and the right partner for you
do you have a do you have any do you
have any contacts well i actually do
have a few
i don't know if they're your type but
i'm going to send them over right after
we finish here
tell me a little bit about your entrance
into you know the make it big build a
company
uh and and some of your outlook into the
entrepreneurial scene
well yeah i obviously am very big right
now especially on linkedin
um you know just started my company and
so you know i i think being successful
is just uh
you know it's essential for success you
know to be successful i mean and that's
part of it obviously money
um and so i you know obviously don't
have any money but i'm trying to beg my
way to get some money and so
actually i was going to ask you about
that because obviously you you meet with
a lot of people and investors so
could can could i get some money yeah
just send me your bank info i'll just
have a few people
uh transfer the right my puppy pal
there you go exactly eddie you're
coming from england to the united states
getting married building a company
you have some interesting tips on and
your outlook on
on how to be on being successful to
become successful which which makes
perfect
sense to me i have to say but i have to
hear a little bit more about
about your mindset because it is pretty
unique
yeah my mindset is basically just don't
hesitate you know no fear
just just ask for what you want just to
just be transparent
i think if if more people were
transparent just ask what they wanted
like
i need money so i ask you for money if i
need contacts i ask you for
contacts you know if i if i want to get
married
then i just ask you for for what i need
and like for example what do you need
from me
it's it's pretty simple i just i think
we make it more complicated in business
than it needs to be
we really do make it i think more
complicated that needs to be and i love
that outlook so what what do you need
you know in the day-to-day life as an
entrepreneur working to become
successful
um i i need my money and also need fame
because when i'm famous i can make money
and then obviously i'll be really happy
when i've just got money and fame
so so to me that's just ultimate success
is is just
there's those two things i mean that
that's what success is about right
100 and your ability you know that
you're trajectory to becoming
famous and making money part of that is
through the shark tank show right and i
believe that you're you have some
some pretty incredible ambitions that
are that are obviously going to take
place so tell me a little bit about
those
yeah i'm going to fly far on kevin's
chair and then
kevin will not be on there anymore and
i'll be the primary primary shark i mean
that's that's exactly what's going to
happen you know and also i'm
going to basically purchase elmo from
sesame street and put in
him in his own um company which is going
to be
called el money so so basically he's
going to he's going to have his own
financial company
and so that's what i'm going to do and
also i'm going to go into space
so i've been chatting to people at
spacex and pretty much
decided that i'm also going to be one of
the first entrepreneurial puppets to go
into space
i i believe that i mean so obviously the
first part is
saying it and and doing it why
why elmo why you know why why go into
the puppet scene
so i see a pattern here
well i i like red things so for example
like the red gummy bears and also elmo's
red
and so um i think you know talent is
very important so he's of he has a good
track record
i i don't and so if i acquire him for
like a hundred thousand red gummy bears
then
you know i can make money from him so so
you know he's grown up a little bit and
so i i think
him to transist to puppetpreneurs which
is my my company and my youtube channel
would would be a smart move for me i
mean that's that's what success is about
is
is about getting talented people or
talented puppets you know like for
example like
can i can i hire you of course i thought
that's the whole point of my company
okay so what would you do wow that's a
tough interview question i thought this
was we were
doing a job interview now i'm guessing
it's actually real well i don't know
what i can do i can i can
you know talk to people i have fun
talking to people
i love hearing their stories i don't
know if you know if i'm if i'm good at
you know acting upon that but i love
hearing people's stories is that enough
okay okay so you're hired so so you'll
be working free for the next year
wait we talked gummy bears after that
year
maybe one maybe green you can start for
green and then go to red
so basically you're going to work free
for a year and then what will happen is
is that after that year
i'll probably fire you and find someone
better but that that's okay
but we can discuss that maybe i like
that because is that how you do
is that is that how is that how yes i
like that because you know a lot of
investors give me
this this tip of of higher of higher
slow and fire fat now i do like that
you're hiring fast as well
because it didn't take too much
convincing and i love that but i also
love the idea that you already know when
you're gonna fire me
so we don't have to have that whole
uncomfortable scene where we go over my
problems
you can just basically you can go for
six months and basically just be in fear
most of the time and and
sorry not being fair and then just know
it's coming and then
like everyone's just it's true it's
transparency you know it's transparency
so i see a few trends here one is you're
saying you know this whole idea of you
know
of money as a salary and and success as
part of you know looking over your
linkedin and resume that none of that is
true because you can just say okay
you know what i'm going based off of
color and i'm going based off a
different commodity
which obviously should be gummy bears
right
exactly and then and also go ahead
yeah gummy bears and then you know just
gifts you know
so for example you you send me i'll be
your boss so you send me gifts and then
that will determine whether you stay for
like six months and
in one day now i understand and
then obviously the whole dynamic changes
and obviously i get more work done you
get more out of it
and that's how we all become successful
yeah i mean i i work you into the ground
and then at some point you know in the
future then you'll
you know just take care of yourself so
eddie give me this whole grand strategy
behind puppet printers because you're
doing a lot you're thinking about a lot
of different
ways to strategically no it's a climb
climb your way to the top
break it down for me break it down into
manageable pieces
well i my mission is to make
entrepreneurs smile because basically
they
are just so you know for example on the
computer until like two in the morning
just looking at the same screen not
being happy getting depressed and i want
to give some relief to entrepreneurs so
to my job is to meet other entrepreneur
puppets and then
show them to you and and help them to be
famous and then the humans can come
along and just for
entertainment like this it's just a
basically a way to for puppets to have
world domination
so take advantage of the humans and
puppets will dominate
therefore the whole world will be
happier you see that's what i was
alluding to because i felt that there
was something there of that line and i
just needed to hear you say because now
because obviously i'm not as smart and i
need
i need articulation
i actually think you're very smart
coming from you eddie that's uh
that that's amazing give me some advice
that you would give me as a young
entrepreneur i'm gonna go start my own
journey i don't have the privilege of
being a puppet myself so obviously i'm
i'm inferior in that regard but i need i
still feel like i can extract some
insights from you
on what i should be doing as an
entrepreneur
yeah don't bother get it get a job
seriously like what would be better for
you to do it's too risky i mean
what i'm doing is pretty out there so
quick quit early
and uh take a low paid job
or you know come with me and get paid
nothing and basically just be a slave
so what's my ambition then what's the
ambition of being a young entrepreneur
if at the end
it's nothing um
that's a great question i mean i'm
really just confused i'm just
you know you know what it's like you
just kind of start and then you just
don't know what to do
so i probably not the best person to ask
because really just i'm just
you know just trying to find my way i
mean maybe you could i mean
what do you what are you passionate
about i'm passionate about
first of all i love technology i don't
know you know how much you're into that
kind of thing but i love you know
algorithms and you know the whole math
behind it
it's not very entertaining but but i do
love it that sounds very depressing
it kind of is until you get something
done and then it's really awesome
so maybe you should you maybe should get
into that you know i'm trying to but i'm
but i'm still missing how are you
depressed i'm missing that whole you
know then what so
okay fine i have something cool that i
built but then what do i do with it
just give it to somebody
and and and then and then you could be
there non-paid employee
i mean i'm just i'm just telling you
what i think we should do but maybe i
should just go through a course or
something like to learn this stuff
because
because i i don't i don't really know
well i think a lot of it is about
intuition and i
i trust your intuition is this how
you're going about it
well i just started meditating so i'm
probably not the best person to ask like
i get really frustrated after like one
minute
ah do you meditate i don't but tell me
tell me about your meditation
and how that helps you well it doesn't
help me right now it's really annoying
so
i basically closed my eyes for like like
one minute and i get really angry
and and so right now i hate meditation
but
i'm open to if it makes me money then
i'm i'm open to doing it for like
two minutes maybe like maximum and so
that's the that's sort of the goal
like two minutes every minute
just one minute one minute to then two
minutes and then
hopefully i'll get some massive insight
that will make me a billion dollars
because apparently that's what
meditation does but i'm not too sure do
you know any billionaires as well
i know a couple they don't have the same
mindset though even though i think that
you know it's 2021 so everything is
crazy so everything can change
what about celebrities do you know
celebrities
i'm hopefully you're you're going to be
a very big celebrity soon and i'm
i'm happy to be part of this you know
early journey for you what about what
about
you not do you not like jessica alba
she has a company i do know i didn't
know she was famous i i didn't know her
i think she's pretty famous and also i
wanted to be my wife maybe
dada can help but i i think she's also
looking so
maybe okay would you like would you like
to come to the wedding
i'm i'm expecting to be the best man
what do you mean if i'm making the
connection i need to be the best man
you want to be my best man yes i do
that would be awesome you so basically
you walked me up the aisle is that right
no no that's not right
no i don't think that's right i i don't
think so eddie what do you do you stand
next to me or something
you'll be like much taller than me and
then my only fear would be that jessica
albert that would then want to get
married to you and i'll just be left
standing there and then my best man
would basically
screw me over i hate to break it to you
eddie but if after you know she sees
me standing next to you and then she
changes like this maybe what you had
wasn't that real
in the start
yeah that's that's honest
i'm sorry that's what you get from a
human i i i i
i think i just wait i'm having like a
spiritual awakening
i think that meditation is kicking in
wow like you're a real cover
so anyway i want to ask you a question
like who's been your best guest apart
from me
wow who's been my best guest well you're
really going to get me in trouble
because we had a
quite a few people on the show that were
really amazing and i
and i'm going to give the very political
and politically correct answer that
oh come on you know it there's always
one that stands out but you don't want
to say because you want you're a people
pleaser
michael do you realize you're people
pleaser isn't that the role of a host of
a show to be a people pleaser
that's true well not with my show if
people come on there i'd be like hey
michael was my best interview
and i'm just going to say that out loud
and actually if someone turns up and
they're not very
good i'm just going to tell them because
i am transparent eddie and we have this
on record
in the world transparency and honesty
and is that getting you
far in your line of business because you
want to get famous you want to be a
successful
entrepreneur so how does that
transparency kick into place here
it's not working out very well for me
right now honestly right right do you
have friends maybe i need a daddy
not really no why is that
that's a great question i'll i'll be
your friend but but i also want to do
business together
i don't know if that can work well
come on eddie you're an entrepreneur
pull yourself together
i don't i don't want to do the podcast
thing
okay eddie we'll move on to happier
subjects we'll move on to happier topics
you're going to replace kevin on the
shark tank
what's going to happen oh yeah kevin
yeah yeah so you're sitting there you're
getting a pitch
what's what is it what is eddie bringing
to the table investing in entrepreneurs
not with gummy bears i hope
um honest advice you know i think that's
valuable that's pretty worth like 90
i mean i feel i've already got my worth
from this show just from your honest
advice
right i mean it's life-changing you know
to have to have someone on your show
that can show vulnerability and cry and
be honest i mean it's you know it's
it's probably gonna open a lot of people
up you know so back to uh
back to shark tank yeah 90 for solid
advice in a bag of
of 100 gummy bears with one red one
you know actually saying so so we you're
paying a hundred thousand gummy bears
for
elmo you're only giving 100 as an
investment i think there's some
some interesting unit economics that
we're going to have to work through
together now that i'm
working for you after this well that's
because most people that come onto shark
tank are stupid
and they're worth 100 bears
i love that eddie this is the moment
right here right
now we have investors entrepreneurs
perhaps even a billionaire or two
watching this i want to give you the
spotlight
to give your best pitch for
puppetpreneurs this is where you're
gonna make it big eddie
this is it go
wow uh
make me famous
and give me some money so that
i can get a really big house and
live in it what do i get as an investor
respect from me you know that's the most
and also maybe like i can i can i can
you know play with the kids and be
around the family you know just i'm kind
of family
want to be a family guy so maybe you
know they can put my their hand up me
and
and i can allow that space you know to
be able to
make people smile i mean that's what a
puppet's supposed to do you know i love
that i mean that this guy down here i
mean
he's pretty ugly but you know got his
hand up there
eddie what are you passionate about what
are you doing you have a puppet
do you have a puppy i don't i don't i
really want one though why
why i don't know do you can you imagine
being around all the time like you could
just lay on my belly as you
did you put your head on the pillow like
mr pillow i'm not excited about walking
down the street with you and giving some
honest advice to others
yeah that'd be awesome i think so
i think we would make a great pair you
know
what we call our joint podcast show like
two-minute two-minute loses wow
that's a really good one wow did you see
what i did there that's that that's just
intuition
i love it almost like i love your
catchphrase don't
take business too seriously which i know
you've worked that's right
that's right don't take anything too
seriously everyone's too serious
like people watching this right now
see i love it share this video make us
grow famous so that we can buy things
that we don't really need
exactly that's what entrepreneurship is
all about
that's very honest honest
and real eddie what are you excited
about what really gets you going
well i i really want to you know just
take over hollywood and i'm going to
have my own pixar movie i think that
would be awesome
are you going to star in it you know
absolutely
and elmo yeah and i'm gonna give you
like a roll
whoa
you could be like a voice you know
because you're not you're kind of ugly
so that would be best
um i don't i don't i don't know if i
like this engagement eddie this is this
is
hard to hear i'm used to hearing all
like you know praises and
you know people being politically
correct and i don't like this
doesn't feel so you basically like
people lying to you is what you've
liked for most of your life is that
correct doesn't that come down to it a
lot
though
wow i love you
now i don't know if you're being honest
or not you're giving me the politically
correct answer
i'm always going to be honest and during
this 20 minutes i've kind of just
find myself just a little bit in my
heart you know
well i i love that these 20 minutes are
making both of us think
and because i think that's what it takes
uh to me i'm i'm
yeah i think it was making us think and
it's also gonna really confuse some
people
i really do i really do think so how can
we help them through this confusion
after they see this episode
like i i think the best thing is
honestly donations
like do you need donations for this show
uh well i
obviously do i i love getting donations
for the show but actually i think this
is a point to to promote you know your
endeavor so
going back to pop it pal
puppetpreneurs but no but but you've
mentioned that the way to transfer money
would be through puppetpal
oh puppetpower yes um but honestly if
they just go visit eddie furbottom on
linkedin and youtube
puppetpreneurs and just watch it like
but they have to watch it all the way
through because like you like this with
the data
is that what's important is like
engagement and and
actually watching all the way through so
don't just like watch a minute you have
to watch it all the way through
because then that will tell youtube that
i'm really awesome and then put it to
more people which then will make me
money and then make me famous so
that's really the sequence of events i
need to have happen well i think you
have the most important thing figured
out and then that's how it works because
i
i don't think that i have to figure it
out after you know 300 plus episodes so
i'm i'm already gaining something from
300 wow
that's like do you know what that's like
that's like the movie you just hit 300
episodes
you're in the ring you're a warrior you
are in there just like battling it and
you've gone all the way through
and this is like my motivational speech
that's now linking 300 episodes to you
being a warrior and that you're awesome
and that you're fighting off all the
demons
and in fact like you're gonna totally
like dominate life in rome
so you should move to italy i think that
we just went through that whole
emotional rollercoaster of a whole
feature film in just 20 minutes eddie
that that was that was impressive i i
can't thank you enough for taking
time out of your pressure schedule to
come here i know that you have a lot
going on and
you have a lot of ambitions and you have
i already don't you have to hire and
fire a lot more people today so i
appreciate this opportunity most of all
both interviewing you but also working
for you shortly after so
we'll talk in a second but before we
leave the most important question which
is
three words you would use to describe
yourself
ugly not rich
stupid exactly what you need i love it
eddie thank you very very much for
coming on my show
best of luck i'll see you on shark tank
i'll see you in our office you'll tell
me where that is
starting tomorrow you're going to be
starting on monday so i'll see you on
monday morning and just make sure you
wear pajamas
great but i wanted i want a upfront
gummies
and just you know to make sure that we
have a right engagement here
did you hear that
did you hear what you just said i'll
i'll forgo the upfront i
i really don't want to miss out you're
fine eddie
thank you very very much best of luck
with puppet puppetpreneurs
uh i look forward to talking again after
you're
rich and famous that you can make me
virgin famous and have a great rest of
the day
okay you put the phone down all right i
will
thank you take care
[Music]